[Music]
he's repeating not only in december last
year but in january this year in
february this year my goal is to have
baltic countries poland romania and
bulgaria they're repeating that right
now
so why i should not believe mr putin
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
former economic advisor to russian
president vladimir putin andrei leonov
welcome to trigonometry
well thank you for inviting me hello
it's such a pleasure to have you on the
show uh many of our audience will be
familiar with your background and who
you are but for those of them who are
not please tell everybody who are you
how are you where you are what has been
your journey through life that lead you
to be sitting here talking to us
all right so life is long so i will not
have enough time to discuss all my life
but uh essentially i'm economist by
training and i spend most of my time uh
by being economist and writing economic
stuff and advising on economic policy
it happened that i spent some time about
six years advising uh
mr putin as
economic advisor to the russian
president i will sir
being a russian sharp part to g8
club of
the most developed uh and then
democratic countries at least
some of them still democratic
one of them already not
um
uh in yet 2005 uh after a serious uh
series of serious conversations
with my uh former boss i
resigned from both of my positions as
russian sherpa and uh advisor
uh after that
in some time i left russia
[Music]
and now i'm
living in the united states working
for the center for security policy
and also spend some time in ukraine
working for the ukrainian institute for
future
so it's my short story
fantastic well we are going to draw on
your economic expertise in a moment but
one of the questions i think a lot of
quite normal people are asking at the
moment is
uh they're trying to establish how
rational vladimir putin is there's a
sort of mad vlad narrative that's
emerging in the west among some people
uh so before we get into the economics
the sanctions the war the military
situation what is your assessment of
president putin's mental state you've
seen some of the speeches that he's
given that seem quite belligerent and so
on what do you make of that conversation
first of all
i don't buy that description that you
have mentioned before so he's pretty
rational person probably he's the most
rational person that ever met my in my
life
and he continues to be
as so
he's very calculated he's very
determined
and he's
accurately balancing when he tried to
portray himself as the so-called if you
use this word mad
uh but that is just for producing uh
some impression on weak people
especially my politics of the western
countries
some western leaders
like uh to be fiat
and
mr putin knows that and that is why he
plays the game or plays the show with
them
he pretends to be mad and they pretend
to be feared
so um that's exactly what both sides uh
would like to do
so interesting
when putin pretend to be met and uh
threatening with the eucalypt blackmail
so some people like president biden
prefers to
believe him or some european leaders i
say no no we we cannot participate we
cannot participate uh in any serious uh
resistance to mr putin so that is why
okay let's
be fearful and do nothing
that's exactly what medium point wants
so that is why he's very very rational
and calculated
and speaking of rational calculated the
obvious question and people are trying
to answer for themselves in the last
couple of weeks uh you were talking
since 2014 about the fact that there
would be a full-scale war i've been
talking since 2014 i'm far less i have
far less expertise than you but it was
quite obvious to me also
what if putin is such a rational person
explain to our western audience what is
the rationale for his invasion is it
nato expansion is it his own
expansionist desires is it other things
why has he done this
uh
he is rational but he's russian not in
our sense so not in a sense of civilized
people who would like to live in peace
and democracy
with the rule of law he's a russian in a
sense of uh being imperialist
so he uh started to talk about keith as
his what dreams as we used to say in
russia
from year 2001 so already for 21 years
so and for these more than two decades
he
has written so many texts he has made so
many statements all of them
were devoted to ukraine and to kiev so
that is why he never hided his
intentions
uh to establish control over ukraine to
capture kiev
and uh his statement about the ukraine
does not right to be an independent
state so that is why it's not too hard
uh to predict that he would do something
moreover he started to do uh
something like uh these aggressive
actions
from year 2003
uh and that is why it was yet 2003 in
the strip tuesday in the strait of
church in the year 2008 he proclaimed in
conversation with george bush junior
that ukraine does not have right to
exist in year 2014 he uh captured and
occupied crimea and studied war in
donbass and in year 2021 he published a
long essay explaining that ukraine uh
should be
put under his control so it was rather
hot not to see what he was doing and
what he was saying
andre
i'll never forgive myself if i don't ask
this question so i have to ask it
what was it like to work for vladimir
putin in the uk we say would you go for
a point with him is vladimir putin
somebody that you could imagine going to
a bar drinking vodka with
is he a sociable man does he have
another side to him or is it what you
see is what you get
i never did what you have mentioned
right now
i never
went to bob with mr putin i was
an economic advisor and i was invited to
be an economic advisor actually i've
been invited three times because twice i
declined his invitation and i agreed
only for the third time
so and i was working as economic advisor
my idea was to bring economic growth to
russia so i was advising on economic
policies that would be good would be
necessary to start and to continue uh
very
fast economic growth and i uh succeeded
in that the uh ten years uh that the
policies that i recommended were
implemented the world best period in the
russian economic history russian gdp
doubled russian gdp per capita doubled
and private consumption per capita grew
2.3 times
within 10 years uh this is one again
once again its best
economic growth period in the history of
the country so
that is why from the uh
kind of the professional point of view
um it was very productive for me it was
very productive for
145 million of russian citizens
and
the next question i was going to ask
you've kind of alluded to
do you feel that he was a competent
leader
let's forget about the war in ukraine
but just when he came to power do you
think he was a competent leader the way
you think he ran the country was
effective particularly when you compare
it with former leaders certainly people
like yeltsin
you need to understand that i did not
discuss with him how to attack ukraine
and how many of you yeah
yeah
right i i an economist and just i talked
to him on economic policies and state of
economy
so and i found
him as a person who is ready to listen
and
to learn something that he didn't know
he was really uh rather unique
in this regard compared to other russian
political leaders and after that i met
many other leaders including leaders
from the west and he was very very
unique in this regard because he tried
to understand very complicated issues
and some of them he learned and some of
them he started to implement in his
actions in his policies and it is one of
the explanations why uh that period 10
years period was such a good from the uh
point of view of economic growth so it
was his contribution to this result no
no doubt
it's interesting that it seems it's at
least to me and i'm sure you'll explain
to me why i'm wrong but there seems to
be a contradiction of what you're saying
on the one hand he is the guy who learns
who is uh smart who who developed you
know listen to you and other people
around him um to to deliver things for
the russian people and he's very
rational yet at the same time his
imperialist ambitions
have taken him to war in ukraine which
will hurt russia would you not say
no i completely agree with you actually
i came to the same conclusion uh about
16 or 17 years ago that is why i
resigned uh from position of economic
advisor but uh initially when i started
to work uh
with in the presidential administration
it was a quite a shock for me because
before that i thought that those people
who would like to have economic
prosperity for own citizens would not do
imperialistic policies and they would
not destroy democratic institutions
and they would not destroy rule of law
and to my great surprise because
francis fukuyama did not
explain to us
in his
end of history he saw that everything
should be in one direction
everyone who is supporting liberty or
democracy and well-being of people
that's just one direction
uh and all
evils will be on the other side
but i was able to see with my own eyes
that somebody could be or just a person
with whom i was working for some time at
the same time is uh have
having intentions to improve
uh living standards of people to have an
economic roles but at the same time he's
really very serious in destroying
uh
liberal institutions democratic
constitutions institutions of law and
after that to start imperialistic wars
at the same time
uh let me ask you andre if i may i asked
you about nato expansion and we we
didn't quite address it there are people
like
uh john mayersheimer or vladimir posner
or
there are others who say the reason that
this has happened is the west uh
particularly nato pushed closer to the
borders of russia uh vladimir vladimir
posner for example would say that putin
wanted to work with the west he wanted
russia to join nato he wanted all poor
you know fluffy mr putin wants is for
the nato not to have its missiles and
troops on its borders uh you know
ukraine is the equivalent of mexico for
the united states and expanding nato
into that area is is very threatening to
russia and that's the reason all of this
is happening what do you say to them
you know it's very interesting um and
what you're asking for and especially
because uh these two presentations to
shows of both uh john misheim and uh
vladimir postner became a viral
due to policies of youtube because i saw
both of those shows some time ago when
there were just
several tens of thousands uh people
watched it but after the policy of
youtube
that recommended
everywhere and to everybody the number
of people who were forced to watch those
show uh right up to 20 million or
something like that so that is why it's
a particular policy of our platform our
youtube platform uh to force people to
watch these
two shows which from my point of view
are completely wrong
they cro wrong in their assumptions
they're wrong in their attitudes to be
correct i would say both of them uh at
least john misham is definitely he
belongs to the same class of uh
thinkers who prefer to see
empires
uh in these worlds who does not give
right of small nations
or small countries to be independent
he's thinking it's actually it's a very
uh
well i would say rather spread a rather
popular view among some political
thinkers that not every country deserves
to be independent and there are some
small countries that should go under the
so-called umbrella of
super powers
but
but isn't that true though i mean look
at the cuban missile crisis for example
did cuba really have sovereignty when
the soviet union tried to move its
nuclear missiles onto cuba
uh the united states said you we don't
care about your sovereignty we care
about our security isn't that john
marshall would argue that's what
vladimir putin is doing
okay but it was in 1962
it was 60 years ago
where living in year 2022.
so and after
uh end of the it was a actually uh mid
of the cold war
and in 91 a cold war was officially
declared finished so the soviet union uh
disintegrated was epoxies to exist
and there was a possibility actually
that was claimed by many people
including by francis fukuyama whom i
mentioned many others but okay yes
during the cold war during the world war
that's a world war
and in many regions of the world it was
a hot war so after the finish of three
world wars first second and the cold war
it is possible for
small nations so medium-sized nations to
be really independent to have real
sovereignty
because nobody should threaten them
so that is why if something happened in
the past okay we can find many
historical examples uh before the first
world war second world war uh and you
cuba will be not the only one but we are
living in the 21st century
and nobody should use the instruments of
the 19th century or 18th century or even
the first half of 20th century against
neighbors against small countries
why ukraine or any other country could
not live like a luxembourg
or switzerland luxembourg and
switzerland are smaller nations than
ukraine nobody threatened luxembourg and
switzerland from neighbors
why ukraine does not have the same right
as luxembourg so i'm just playing
devil's advocate here because
emotionally i agree with you very much i
do think that ukraine should have the
right to do and choose any direction
that it wants and i have family in
ukraine and i want them to have the same
freedoms and the same quality of life
that i do here in london of course i do
but on the other hand
if if a what is perceived as a hostile
power to the eu placed its nuclear
missiles or attempted to place its bases
in luxembourg i think other eu countries
would be concerned
well i'm all i'm getting at with you is
isn't it true to say
that of course a country like russia
which perceives the united states as a
strategic adversary at best
placing its bases or placing its
missiles on its borders
is a concern and when it happened with
latvia stone lithuania etc that was a
little bit different because those
countries were never in the long history
part of the russian empire
but but ukraine is different because
there's that kind of you know
emotional element too as well and it's a
much bigger country too
no but this is uh if there is something
that is quite opposite to what has been
claimed by devil's advocate or mr putin
because essentially ukraine did not
place nuclear missiles on its territory
there was nobody
among ukrainian politicians
among ukrainian statesmen
even the public
leaders
in ukraine who would ever suggest to
placing to deploy nuclear missiles on
ukraine that would threaten moscow or
russia no
the case was
exactly different
ukraine in 1994 signed budapest
memorandum
through which
ukraine
removed all nuclear weapons that were
exactly located on the ukrainian
territory and gave all nuclear weapons
to russia so that is why if there is a
threat this is threat from russia to
ukraine not from ukraine to russia
and actually there is a constitution of
ukraine in which stated very clear there
should be no foreign basis on ukrainian
territory
and there was only one
foreign uh military bases based on the
ukrainian territory it was a russian
navy base in sebastopol in crimea so
that is why if
with any threat to anyone it was threat
from russia to ukraine not vice versa
and until the very last moment ukraine
was never played
any potential that ukraine never invited
united states or nato to deploy nuclear
missiles or to deploy u.s troops on a
ukrainian territory or deploy a
us on native basis on ukrainian
territory the majority of ukrainian
population were against nato membership
until putin attacked ukraine in year
2014 occupying crimea occupied
sevastopol studied war in donbass so
reaction of ukraine to defend itself it
is the result of
putin's aggressive policy and his
aggressions against ukraine
andre
why is it that so many people in the
west were shocked when he invaded and
very few people predicted it
because of the west is living in
different reality
many i would say wesleyan leaders and
western leaders political leaders
and western leaders in the sense of
media and public opinion
they
really
decided that okay the life that they are
enjoying especially in europe and the
northern america over the last several
decades are so good that they
prefer to forget
or prefer uh not to see
reality beyond
europe's borders or north american
borders and there are
thugs
in the world that occupying the highest
position in power in number of countries
there are imperialists the aggressors
and they are using very different
policies and different attitudes and
different actions
from those people who are living in
europe just people pretend to see that
that part of the world does not exist or
if they would preach
to some kind of good
cause or so-called diplomacy which means
doing nothing
that would
help to save
thousands of lives from attacks of thugs
and imperialists this is just mistakes
and actually by the way uh you asked me
before whether mr putin is a rational
and very he whether he understands
what's going around the world
mr putin understands understands very
well what is going around the world
but many western leaders do not
hey francis do you like podcasts and
politics no mate i'm a real man i'm only
interested in football birds and fast
cars last time you tried to drive a car
you had a panic attack when you got
overtaken by a granny she was driving
very aggressively and used disgusting
language for a woman of her age well for
those of you who do like podcasts and
politics then you have to check out the
lost debate it's a podcast and youtube
show for political eclectics who want to
escape their media bubbles and engage in
good faith with ideas from across the
political spectrum it's three friends
from across the political spectrum
discussing the big issues of the day
ravi's a former obama staffer and school
principal corey's a former fox radio
news host and ricky's a new york post
columnist instead of being at each
other's throats they focus on bringing
new perspectives to the table in
constructive debates that sound less
like crossfire and more like discussions
between real people they sound like us
apart from the whole sound like real
people bit that and they might actually
know what they're talking about check
the lost debate out on youtube or
wherever you get your podcast
do you think the west has done enough in
order to support ukraine
or do you think that actually what they
should do is they should have put up
maybe stronger sanctions maybe done more
particularly
because maybe putin will then advance
and try and take other nations
the short answer is definitely no
and we can discuss what uh the west
might do
one very basic principles actually is
coming from our earlier uh
discussion
is that if tanks are already rolling
they cannot be stopped by sanctions
that's a very simple
and not very pleasant lesson
to leaders to public opinion to regular
people the ordinary people
if already war
is studied
if bombers are flying if missiles are
shelling
cities and killing people and tanks are
rolling you cannot stop them by
resolution of united nations general
assembly you cannot stop them by
sanctions whatever sanctions will be
just please let me just remind everybody
in 1939 the soviet union
uh studied war against finland it is
so-called soviet finnish war or winter
war as it is known in finland a couple
of weeks after that the soviet union has
been expelled from the league of nations
the question is
expelling of a league of nations or from
the united nations if is if it would be
today whether it stopped stalin to
continue his attack on finland
no
he continued this war for another
hundred days
whether this expulsion from the league
of nations stopped stalin from
occupation of baltic countries no
in 1940
whether that fact
stopped putting uh stopped stalin it's
interesting it's like a
uh fraud so just uh whether it stops
studying from occupation of bessarabe
and nozon bucavin in 1940 no
and actually expulsion from the league
of nations it's a very serious sanction
so it means that this particular very
serious acts that we have seen in the
past
did not stop
stalin
or
hitler
when he actually he himself left league
of nations
so
if the aggressor decides to attack
neighbors membership in any
international organizations or sanctions
of economic type or transportation or
personal sanctions
do not play any role they would continue
this aggression
they would continue their attacks so
that is why it is necessary to change
mind of those people who prefer to think
once again
in those in
in ideas of functions or expansion or
whatever whatever no
for hardware policies for hardware
attacks it should be hardware response
only that can work it's not what you
mean by hardware response andre
it means resistance it means the
forceful resistance do you know when i
mentioned this soviet finish 4 of 1939
1940 do you know when stalin really
stopped the war
when he received
information that the british and french
troops
uh are
embanking on the ships
and are going to be shipped to finland
to fight on the finish site
as soon as stalin received this
information he immediately start
so-called peaceful negotiations and stop
the war
do you know when putin stopped the his
attack on georgia in year 2008
we know this just
not by days we know it's about hours and
minutes
on august 11 year 2008
george bush jr
appeared
in front of the white house
flanked by his minister of defense and
uh assistant uh on
national defense
and proclaimed
that he is directing u.s troops to the
region
and immediately u.s navy
started to move from mediterranean to
black sea
and u.s air force
has been deployed to romania and took
tokyo to the u.s bases
12
hours after that
putin stopped attack on georgie
that's a powerful result of
resistance
of resistant a very powerful country in
this world
united states
for aggression
i take your point andre it's a hard line
and you know it's you argue with it well
what would you say to the people go hang
on a second here if you start down the
part of hardline resistance your words
well i mean we're on the we're on the
path to world war three
and the second part of the question
andre is you've used the example of
stalin which again is a good point but
let's be fair stalin didn't have nukes
did he
okay
mr putin
first of all stalin had nukes
but not in 39
but in 49 okay in 49 okay he already had
the nukes and after that there was a
korean war
and how korea have been saved at least
part of kiri have been saved
with resistance with resistance from the
united states united kingdom and number
of other western countries who supported
and defended
south korea
its only way to do it and actually even
stalin did not use nukes
in korean war
what about mr putin okay in year 2008
during russian georgian war mr putin did
have nukes
did he use it when
americans moved their troops into the
region
no
what happened in year 2015 when the
russian bomber violated turkish airspace
for 40 seconds turkish jet
shot down
russian bombers
and two people one of them pilot had
been killed
what was the reaction of mr putin to the
action of turkey not united states toki
just did it alone
what was the reaction
mr putin promised to punish turkish
tomatoes
[Music]
but he did not do even that
so and
after that none of russian bombers
violated turkish space anymore
in year 2018 the group of russian
mercenaries
uh were trying to capture uh the gas
plant in there azor in syria
what happened after that
americans with kurds
destroyed this group and 200 mercenaries
were killed
russian mercenaries what was the
reaction of mr putin
nothing
deep silence
for four years that continues up today
putin never mentioned it he not
not even used nukes he never mentioned
dukes
he never mentioned this case
what is going right now during this war
against ukraine
what
turkey did turkey did something that no
other country did
turkey essentially participated in this
war
on the site of ukraine
do you know about drones yeah no
drones are very well known
turkey closed straits
bosporus and dardanelles
and the russian navy
has been left in the mediterranean and
against sea
those ships those navy that could
shell and bombard or death sonic alive
in other ukrainian cities so
turkey closes trades
what we hear from mr putin whether he's
threatening to use nukes against turkey
no
he never mentioned it publicly
so once again we can see not only in
1939 with mr stalin not in yet 2008 with
putin uh versus georgia but right now
today
some countries and some leaders prefer
not to be afraid
to resist
what is reaction from mr putin
nothing
but those leaders who actually place for
mr putin
pretend to be afraid to pretend to be
fearful and that is playing this game
with mig-29 from poland slovakia and
bulgaria it was a decision of mr biden
not to give those jets to ukrainians
because of nukes because such a threat
okay it's a game it is a game for four
hands as we say in russia so it's a game
of two
uh people
one person is playing role of the bad
cop another
is playing the role of good cop but
they're playing together against ukraine
so okay uh i i know that a lot of people
will be
uh interested in your perspective and
i'm very interested in the perspective
you bring that's not an argument i've
really heard much in the western
mainstream media at least
but it is quite a scary argument for
people because essentially you're asking
us to play chicken with nuclear weapons
in in the modern age in which the use of
nuclear weapons would end all life on
earth
is that really a risk do you think the
united states should be taking
it's very strange mr putin was
threatening to use nuke so he's playing
at least in those threats so many times
that those who prefer to not to hear
what mr putin is doing just
who is realistic who is understanding
what's going on
mr putin is already using it as a black
male
as a threat so that is why if you refuse
to do it you are in a big position so it
means you already surrender
in this battle whatever you can call a
real war or psychological battle or
whatever just if one side
is openly refusing to use some
particular instrument or some particular
weapons
it means you already surrendered
because the other side
is ready to escalate and if you are not
ready to escalate it means you are ready
for defeat and means you are ready to
defeat it
the only way just okay just let's
uh imagine that we are not playing the
geopolitics but you happen to be
in the night or in the evening in the
dark corner and
some facts approaching you with very
clear intentions
that's what are they going to do with
you or with your friends or with your
family okay what is your reaction
your reaction either to defend yourself
and your close ones
or to run
if you are not if you are going to read
bible
to that person or those persons
okay you probably would not win this
battle
so that is why easy you fight
it's not a guarantee that you can win
but at least you will try you have a
chance
or if you say oh i'm not going to use my
force
i'm going to read good book to to that
person okay what are you going to what
is going to happen
you will be
in a very bad position
okay i think it's probably enormous
simplification but doesn't matter let's
get into yours
by the way it is the same absolutely the
same stories this is psychological
warfare
leaders of the country
refuse to use the instruments and the
weapons that in their disposal so they
it means they don't have them
just if you do not use
nukes even your imagine imaginative uh
some kind of possession so it means you
don't have it it means that just you end
up in the position of lag laptop you are
not united nations uh you're you're not
united states you're not united kingdom
you're just luxembourg or switzerland or
finland
yeah but the the fact that nuclear war
can end all life on earth i think plays
very much into making it a bigger issue
than just you being mugged for your
money by a thug in the street there's
that's exactly the that's exactly the
point that mr putin is using because
okay because you are thinking in that
particular approach okay just in the in
this particular line okay and he's a
very different one okay that's exactly
the point you're ready
ready to be defeated you're ready
i'm ready to be defeated so explain this
to me what are your policy prescriptions
in this moment how should the united
states because let's be clear britain
france germany they can all do things
but at the end of the day it is up to
the united states it's the most powerful
country in the world by far it's a
decision maker on these issues what
would you have america do right now
that's another mistake by the way
constantine okay because we accustomed
to think about the united states of the
most powerful
uh country in this world
and that is why uh people just
tend to believe okay so we cannot do
anything just let's wait until
uh u.s president would do something
we are in a position right now
especially with the arrival of new uh
american president 14 months ago
in a situation where united states
at least under the current
administration is going to do anything
in defense of freedom democracy and
lives of million peoples
around the world and for the first time
uh since 1949 uh since
foundation of nato
uh the western countries three countries
free world
uh found itself in the position
that
they need to
act
without the united states
because the current u.s administration
would do nothing almost nothing
for uh defense of europe
and europe woke up
especially over the last four weeks
in a situation
that if europe itself or european
countries would not act by themselves
so they are rich kim to be attacked
next time
by putin
if he will be able
to
win in ukraine it is absolutely clear
that he will not be stopped he will go
further
and his goals are already known
he issued this ultimatum to nato to the
west to
the united states to europe
in december last year on december 17th
he published two so-called draft
treaties in which he proclaimed
his goal is
so-called returning to
1997
division line in europe
which with the so-called
denaturalization
of central and eastern europe which
means
and actually they mentioned those
countries
estonia latvia lithuania
poland romania bulgaria
should stop to be
members of nato
and it is not only denaturization it is
demilitarization of those countries it
is a text of these documents it's
exactly that's true and i've read those
texts andre so that being the case
what should europe do
in this situation in your opinion
right now as we understand the strongest
army on the european continent is
ukrainian one
it's a kind of
it became known over the last four weeks
and the ukrainian
nation is resisting this attack and this
is the strongest ally of europe
in this battle against tyranny
against despotism
so that is why it's not only due to
humanitarian reasons
it is necessary to support ukraine but
it isn't just for genuine european
interest
to do everything possible and impossible
that the putin's aggression against
ukraine will be the last
one for putin so that is why europe
european countries
well with the united states or without
united states doesn't matter
need to do everything
just to support and to defend ukraine
and now we can discuss what exactly
europe can do but this is a very
important mental point
europe should not allow
ukraine to be subjugated by a criminal's
master
okay great i am with you a hundred
percent
how
all right
crucial point now is no fly zone as we
all know and president zelensky said it
in
all his conversation with western
leaders in his statements to the uk
parliament to the u.s congress to anyone
so just
help us to close the sky
it can be done
in different ways certainly the best way
if the nato
would pronounce no-fly zone over ukraine
that would be the best solution okay
nato is scared it is not turkey turkey
alone can do whatever they like and
actually they
shot
russian bombers in the turkish sky
without any problem but nate is much
smaller and weaker than uh turkey alone
nato cannot do it okay but nato can
provide
ukraine with anti-air weapons with
anti-missile weapons
with many other weapons with heavy uh
military equipment that ukraine needs
and ukraine is splitting to provide
them with all these weapons
and
europe does not provide
that weapons that ukraine needs at this
moment
actually united kingdom is
in a very particular position united
kingdom is leading the so-called
jeff
joint expeditionary force it is a group
of 10 countries
led by the uk
so it is expeditionary force you
the gf can deploy their troops in let's
say west of ukraine it's not necessary
for a gf to participate in the battles
no
jeff would would participate in
peacekeeping missions
they would provide support for
humanitarian convoys
uh bringing ukrainians to europe they
could provide uh
security for those uh convoys with
military equipment
uh to ukraine they would not participate
in the battle so they would be just over
there just to physically present and
actually it would be another deterrent
to mr lukashanka
uh who is still thinking whether to
participate in aggression against
ukraine or not
and actually that would be substantial
real help
of europe
uk and jeff to ukraine
but isn't that really where people's
concern in the west comes from because i
hear what you're saying and i want to
defend people in ukraine from
russian aggression as much as you do but
what happens if nato shoots down a
russian plane or what happens if russia
as it has done already bombs western
ukraine to
to destroy bases for training or
whatever and it's killing british
american or other european countries
soldiers isn't that taking us on the
road to world war three which no one
wants and no one can afford
no first of all the world war iii to
some extent has been announced or
proclaimed by mr putin so that is why if
you
if the west is still don't hear that
it's a problem of the west not of the
reality
so but the best way to stop
this particular war from evolving into
real third world war is just to
participate in that particular actions
and to stop this war to defend ukraine
because if ukraine is defended so
this potential third world war will be
stopped right now
and right there in ukraine but
if it is not stopped
it can evolve and can spread to other
countries including europe this is a
basic lessons of the second world war if
hitler would be stopped in
czechoslovakia he would not go to poland
if he would be stopped in poland he
would not go to france
that's a very basic lessons
we are dealing with the same issue
if putin has not been stopped in georgia
he went to ukraine
if
putin is not stopped in ukraine he would
go further
same story
andre do not worry that what putin has
effectively done here is he's backed
himself into a corner with by deciding
to invade ukraine
and as a result he can't lose
he just can't lose so if we start
pushing up against him and if we start
shooting down russian planes then what
effectively happens
is
not only antagonizing it means that his
presidency becomes more destabilized
which means he's therefore more likely
to do something rash because he feels
his actual position and life is under
threat
no
you know what will happen
if uh nato or jeff or another coalition
of western countries would declare
no fly zone over ukraine and would
provide necessary resources to
secure this no-fly zone
it will be the last day
the russian jets would appear in the
ukrainian sky
it will be a lot of statements from
kremlin
it will be
uh
not very nice words whether we hear but
in terms of actions there will be none
as it was in the case of turkey
that not only declared no fly zone over
turkish space airspace but effectively
shot down the russian bombay
in tokyo closed the strait of basporos
there was nothing no reaction for that
same story will be in this case
russian place will stop to fly
in the ukrainian sky
simple
mr putin as you've seen him
he never did anything
that comes from this particular pattern
he's so much afraid for his life as we
can we have seen
that he's has distance for 10 meters
when he is meeting french president
or his
assistants or his ministers
how such a person could start the third
world war real third world war with
nukes if he is so much afraid for his
personal life
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns
have rock-solid network infrastructure
and incredible customer support they're
in your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code which is of course triggered
as well and you will get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy that tells you
everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
and what would what is the role of china
playing in all of this entree because
initially there were some people worried
that china was going to invade taiwan do
you think that will happen or do you
think that because of because the west
has done more than we anticipated that's
made the chinese think twice
now first of all uh it's better to ask
chinese i cannot talk on behalf of the
chinese leadership okay what are they
going to do
but from what we are
what we know and from we are getting
some kind of additional
information
uh chinese leadership is not happy with
what mr putin is doing in ukraine and
how he's doing
so that is why that gave them a very
unpleasant lesson what might happen if
china would
try to conquer
taiwan with military means
such an ugly picture
does not attract chinese leadership and
that is why you could easily see the
changes in the lexics in these
discussions on the part of chinese
leadership compared to just few months
ago
when a sea
was telling to buy them
that taiwan will be taken
anyway but now they know only peaceful
means
chinese is very interesting
civilizations and interesting leadership
at least for the moment
it does not look like that they are
ready to undertake uh adventure
adventure similar to what mr putin is
doing in ukraine
and francis you want to ask about
sanctions as well didn't you yes so
andre the
one thing that i really wanted to talk
about as constantine alluded to was the
sanctions question now the west have
imposed some pretty strict sanctions
you've you've said that in the short
term that's going to make no no real
difference to the war in ukraine or no
difference at all should i say what
about the long-term entree it will that
ultimately
weaken and destabilize putin's regime
because
russia is going to run out of money or
does it make no difference at all
okay first of all we have a historic
experience with
sanchez introduced against some other
countries
against iran
against south africa against north korea
against cuba
what was the result of all those
sanctions
whether we seen any changes in political
regime of those
countries not a single case
and each of those countries are much
is much smaller
than russia
incomparably smaller incomparably weaker
so if that did not happen if such result
uh did not happen in any of those cases
what is the basis to expect
that all the sanctions would lead in
short term in medium term and long term
with russia
just not there is no basis for that
but actually the west did not introduce
even serious sanctions against russia
for example against iran uh the west
introduced embargo oil and burger
total erlenberger
okay where you can see
oil or gas embargo against russia
no you don't we don't see it so that is
why there is no real sanctions against
russia for the moment
there are some but not a really serious
one because the more serious one
would be sanctions against oil and gas
experts from russia and nobody even
talking about that
but
in this case
it would reduce it was uh reduced the
potential economic potential for new
aggressions i would agree with that but
it would not change the type of thinking
of mr putin in his entourage
andre sorry to jump in your conversation
for us but britain and america have said
they won't be buying russian oil or gas
i understand they're small customers
they're a few percentage of the total
but they have said that so there has
been a little bit of movement on that
hasn't it
no but it's not embargo it's i mean just
okay united states that is buying
whatever one percent of two percent of
the russian oil stop to do it okay what
is it
embargoes
it means that just uh the uh western
countries or countries that do
participate in these policies
proclaim that no one can buy
russian oil and russian gas and they
were ready to introduce sanctions
against anyone who is trying to
participate in such a trade
so it's okay
you as an economic expert you spent a
long time
helping
russia rebuild its economy and get on
its feet and as you said yourself you
were successful in that
how do you assess the sanctions that are
currently in place what will be their
impact on russia's economy and on the
regime
okay the result uh actually uh the most
serious sanctions that have been
introduced by the western countries is
the freezing assets of the central bank
of russia
this is probably the most
important step and with actually rather
short-term consequences
because this particular step essentially
killed exchange rate market in russia
and uh deprived
companies and persons and the government
from foreign exchange now foreign
exchange is russian
it's russian in russia just
not more than five thousand dollars i uh
can be given to either the private
person or to company but also for six
months and actually even that amount is
not available so that is why it's a
single most important act
that you have been uh taking recently
uh
what will be next okay there will be
crisis there will be depression
uh business activity already down by
eighteen percent
uh the forecast for inflation this year
would be sixty to seventy percent
um
uh there is a very important actually
fact is uh exodus of private companies
from russia this is probably even more
important than the decisions taken by
governments the private sector
uh
that actually
nobody
directed them nobody gave them orders
but many of the companies foreign
companies international companies
decided to leave russia regardless of
their investments for last 33 decades
in russia
saying that ok they cannot stay in
russia on under current circumstances
and this is a probably the most
important medium to long-term impact on
a russian economy so russia economy will
come back to
by the level maybe to the 1990s
in terms of uh international isolation
to the period of soviet union
okay but it would not change uh
calculation of mr putin it would not
change
his type of thinking he does not he will
not change
his intentions to wage war against
neighbors so that is why you need to
some to have some instruments and to use
those instruments
i mean
i i find what you're saying
really interesting andre because the
prevailing narrative in the west has
been that we don't get involved we don't
escalate tensions
do you think that's a sign that we've
gone soft
uh it's a sign that you're going to
so-called chamberlain type policy of
1938 that time it was called appeasement
and it was to some extent understood
because it was the first time in the
history and second it was under the
first world war
where britain and france lost uh
hundreds of thousands uh their men and
that is why the
main narrative was to do everything
possible and possible to avoid another
world war
but
okay mr hitler and mr stalin did have
different attitudes and different ideas
and they were exploiting these
so-called pacifistic attitudes of uh
british and french leaders
for their favors so we are dealing
exactly almost with a very similar uh
situation right now
so britain france many other european
countries saying okay we would like not
to be involved okay britain also did not
want to be involved in czechoslovakia
affairs or so that online crisis or uh
to to some kind of to with anxious of
austria with anxious of mehmed
okay what happened after that and after
that happened this third world a second
world war was bombing of london of
coventry and with
war arrived to the british soil so if
you do not stop war in some other places
what will come to you
to your homes
and to your people
are you optimistic andre that this will
be solved that finally the west
will stand up in in the manner that you
wish
or do you think it's
putin is going to keep infringing he's
going to keep moving forward and
eventually
war is inevitable
it depends on the decision of western
leaders
it depends on decision of european
leaders it's not depends on me it
depends on the decision of western
leaders if they would participate right
now with the hardware policies and they
will be able to defend ukraine
yes there is a very high chance that it
will be the last
invasion and last aggression from putin
but
if they
won't do it there is a very high
probability that the war will come to
them to their houses
and
is that really true i mean look
let's say
for the sake of argument that and again
i'm playing devil's advocate because
what you're saying resonates with a lot
of my commentary in recent weeks but i'm
trying to understand my position and
your position and to stress tester so i
know you're taking it in that spirit
anyway
um
let's say ukraine
succumbs to putin he takes over he he
you know he installs a puppet government
etc
do you re are you really trying to tell
people in the west that putin would then
attack a nato country knowing full well
that nato has now taking the situation
seriously and that nato would respond
and nato may strike back even with
nuclear weapons if it feels that it has
to are you really saying he's going to
try and connect kaliningrad for example
through
lithuania and latvia in that way
uh probably you've heard
these stories from survivors of nazi
concentration camps
at least they became relatively popular
if somebody
threatens to kill you
take it seriously
do not think that's a joke
once again it's not from me from
survivors
of nazi concentration camps now we have
a person
who repeated repeating again and again
and again
he is going to come to the 1997 division
line he is repeating not only in
december last year but in january this
year in february this year
on march 8th and 9th it's already two
weeks
after launching his attack on ukraine he
is repeating and then again my purpose
is demonetization of europe my goal is
to return nato to 1997 division line my
goal is to have baltic countries poland
romania and bulgaria they're repeating
that right now
so why i should not believe mr putin
for the reason that you gave earlier
which is you said he is the most
rational person you've ever met and it's
clearly an irrational act to attack a
nuclear alliance isn't it
no looking what uh is a response from
the current u.s administration it's no
doubt for me that if putin moved to
baltic countries there will be no
response from nato
at least
from nato under the current u.s
administration no and that is why putin
is rushing so much because he needs to
finish all his business before year 2024
it is absolutely clear because he he was
actually very quiet
uh when there was another u.s president
he was very close let me ask you all
this question
and under under trump because that's why
would this have happened if trump was in
power
no because under trump the russian
mercenaries have been destroyed in syria
and after that
surprise surprise there was no any
provocations on the russian side in
syria and in ukraine there was a
substantial decline in hostilities and
even those so-called the uh not our
armistice but there was a very
substantial decline
uh in shootings in the
in the line in donbass
everything has changed on january 21st
yet 2021
next day after biden became us president
the shootings the number of shootings
increased 10 times
the number of ukrainian military
being killed in donbass increased 10
times
and exactly from that moment putin
started to mass
his troops on the ukrainian border
it did not have un happened under trump
it happened with mr biden
so that is why uh putin understands very
well that he has a window of opportunity
until biden is the president of the
united states so that is why he would
try to do everything possible and
impossible within this short period of
time until at least
2024.
and andre do you think that the debacle
in afghanistan
influenced putin's thinking
watching what the us did
watching how they messed it up the
complete disaster do you think that just
solidified his decision
no it was just additional uh element in
here thinking because once again i
mentioned this
the putin has started to uh
act actively against ukraine in another
direction from
january 21st 2021 before debacle
in afghanistan because putin knew mr
biden very well because mr biden
traveled to moscow even in soviet times
in 1978
and during the meeting
with his friends from the politburo of
central committee of communist party mr
biden betrayed russian soviet dissidents
it is
on the record mr bukovsky in his archive
actually put all these documents uh on
website you can read them both in
russian and english so that is why the
position of mr biden to watch soviet
dissidence in 78 to south vietnamese in
75 to kurds
uh later
is very well known
mr biden it is his
position through all his life
so that is why afghans were not first
nations that had been betrayed by him
and ukrainians is not the first nation
there are many others
before that case so that is why it was
not hard to predict what kind of
uh policies and what kind of actions
will be from mr biden so that is why
putin started to act on january 21st and
what happened with afghanistan only
reinforced his
thinking because he said it was exactly
that we expected
and you remember by the way it was not
only debacle in afghanistan after what
happened
in afghanistan
what happened mr biden asked mr putin to
deploy
american troops in central asian
countries
in tajikistan and kyrgyzstan in
uzbekistan
what a shock
united states president is asking is
requesting
the international attack an aggressor to
deploy
american troops in the third countries
that's
it's a kind of it's confirmation of the
imperial type of thinking already not
only in part of mr putin but on the path
of mr biden because mr pike biden
is thinking in the type of sphere of
influences
it already gave central asia
to sphere of influence of putin and that
is why he was asking putin for
permission
how it is possible
that a united states president would be
discussing with anybody else except of
the leadership of these particular
countries whether it's possible are not
possible this is a reflection of sphere
of influences in mr biden's
mind and in the minds of his colleagues
well anthony college has been a
brilliant interview thank you so much
for your time uh we're going to ask you
a couple of questions from our local
supporters that only they will see but
before we do we've got a about three or
four minutes uh normally we say what's
the one thing we're not talking about as
a society that we should be but in in
your case i think you have such an
interesting and very different
perspective to most people
what else should people know about
russia and ukraine the current situation
what haven't we discussed what is really
important for people to understand about
this situation that you think isn't
being talked about enough
there are many things to talk about but
just probably one of the uh topics that
we just touched a little bit would be
useful
for our audience
we need to understand that mr putin was
able to act so aggressively and so
cynically and so rudely
only
if there is a support
from some western capitals
if such
support touch it hidden support did not
exist
putin would never attack ukraine
and thousands of people would never be
killed that people should understand and
the basis and the root of these started
support for mr putin is exactly this
particular type of thinking
sphere of influences it's exactly what
you mentioned
you remember when you you remind it
about john schmeyer in his thinking it's
exactly this school of so-called
international relations or diplomacy and
it is exactly the school of thought that
has been shared by mr biden
by uh mr burns cia directed by mr
blinken the state secretary of the
united states and the current youth
administration this is a root this is a
problem this is a problem on the west
and that is why the youtube is spreading
these statements from
john mishmar or vladimir posner and so
on this is a school of sort that deprive
independent nations from their
sovereignty
from their independent choice whether
they would like to develop and to to to
join western union or whether would they
would like to be
within civilization or they would be
under the boat
from uh kremlin or any other dictator
thank you so much for your time it's
been a real pleasure if people want to
follow more of your commentary where is
the best place to do that
okay i'm writing uh regular on my uh
blog in livejournal.com
uh a illarionov.livejournal.com
and also facebook uh
my safest andrei larion of seven
okay so just
welcome
we'll make sure to to get the links in
the description of the video uh we thank
you for now we thank all our audience
for watching and listening uh and we
will ask you a couple of questions for
our supporters in a second but with that
thank you so much thanks for watching
we'll see you very soon with another
brilliant interview like this one and
they always go out wednesdays and
sundays our raw shows go out on
thursdays fridays and saturdays and for
those of you who like your trigonometry
on the go it's also available as a
podcast take care and see you soon guys
how likely is a palace coup
that would remove vladimir putin from
power
you